some 20 to 33 percent of global trade by
sea
passes through the south china sea it is
also home to rich fishing grounds
what if china controlled all of that
it's at the core of international
concern over china's actions
in this body of water located in
southeast asia
the south china sea is claimed almost in
its entirety by
china through what it calls the nine
dash line
this includes territorial claims by
other countries in the region
china has over time militarized many
low-lying islands and coral reefs here
but five years ago today an
international court effectively ruled
chinese claims were illegal particularly
over this part
scarborough shoal a low-lying rocky
outcrop that falls within the
philippines territory
according to the court the binding
ruling by the hague-based permanent
court of arbitration
was in response to the philippines
taking china to court
but china refused to acknowledge the
verdict as a result
to this day filipino fishermen are
prevented from accessing the coveted
fishing areas there
catching fishes like this in the
scarborough shoal has become
increasingly difficult internationally
these filipinos rights to fish here are
recognized
but the fishermen say chinese coast
guards have been chasing
and harassing them in the past years
threatening their livelihood
the problem here is that in our own
fishing territory
we are the ones who are pushed away
we feel that it's as if we are the
thieves in our own area
because the chinese coast guard doesn't
allow us here
that's because beijing never recognized
a 2016 ruling by the hague's permanent
court of arbitration
it wrote that china had violated the
philippines territorial integrity
in parts of the south china sea a
significant
ruling given that china claims almost
all the waters in the region
the islands in the south china sea have
long been china's territory
they are the legacy of our ancestors and
we can't afford to lose a single inch of
them
but the philippines also claims parts of
the resource-rich area
so does taiwan brunei malaysia
indonesia and vietnam
this decades-long conflict has always
been a flashpoint in the region
tension has increased at times since
2013
as china started building and
militarizing artificial islands in the
south china sea
prompting protests like this one in
manila
but the government's position has been
less clear
alternating between rhetoric and
restraint
let us be friends but do not touch
pagasa island and the red
otherwise otherwise
things would be different
but the fishermen aren't convinced they
say the country made
too little pushback against beijing
while seeking investment opportunities
their wish is very simple take action
so they can fish freely in the show
again
let's get more on this i'm joined now
from manila
by richard hidarion he's an analyst and
author of numerous books i must say
including asia's new battlefield us
china
and the struggle for western pacific
richard welcome the 2016 ruling
went in the philippines favor why has it
not been able to exercise its
sovereignty
over scarborough shoal
well as far as international law is
concerned the problem always was
enforcement it's also a question of
diplomacy how do countries
uh that win uh international arbitration
against superpowers like china
how do you how do they leverage uh that
legal victory or
legal warfare uh to gain actually
concessions on the ground so
i think the problem in the case of the
philippines was that it legally was able
to invalidate uh the bulk of china's
claims
across up to 85 percent of the south
china sea and international water
uh we're talking about china's nine dash
line in historic rights claims
uh but the problem was that you know uh
the arbitration case was initiated by
the former
uh benigno aquino administration which
was a liberal american
friendly uh reformist administration but
when the result came out
we had a completely different person in
charge in the philippines which is
president rodrigo duterte who by the way
tried to pee but to china so consciously
over the past
five years the philippine president has
downplayed and sometimes even
denigrated the philippines own legal
victory in order to keep it chummy and
close and intimate with his chinese
friends
and how has that gone down in the
philippines are filipinos buying that
well first of all it hasn't gone down
well with duterte's own
deputies on multiple occasions we have
seen the department of foreign affairs
the defense minister of the country the
foreign minister of the country
reiterating
uh that that arbitration award was final
and binding by inter
per international law and that no matter
what you know anyone says including
china
uh the fact is that this is already a
part of the fabric of international law
and in fairness to duterte's deputies
time and again they have tried to
actually solidify the philippines
position on the ground
not much gains on the scarborough shoal
because of president duterte's
downplaying of the philippines legal
victory including
over who uh should have access uh to
precious resources in the scarborough
shoal
uh but the philippines in fairness over
the past few years thanks to the efforts
of defense
minister uh secretary lorenzana and the
philippine military was able to fortify
its position on the ground in other
disputed areas
including in the theta island and the
spratly so the picture is quite
mixed it's not an unmitigated disaster
but of course the big question was
how could the philippines have done
better in leveraging this legal victory
to get more concessions on the ground
including getting access for its
fishermen there in the scarborough which
is just over 100 nautical miles away
from the philippine coastline correct
what could the philippines have done
better
well many things right i mean the
expectation was if we
had a different president or someone
closer
in terms of ideological outlook and
strategic outlook to the previous
president uh the late president benigno
aquino uh the philippines had many
options one option was to take this
issue this legal victory
out to the u.n general assembly take it
to the eu parliament take it to asean
different fora to put pressure on china
to comply with it of course china will
always say
we don't recognize uh the jurisdiction
of this body
but china also wants to be a respected
leader doesn't want to
be seen as an outlaw or bully so through
a multilateral pressure the philippines
could have got some concessions from the
philippines not to mention
bilaterally the philippines could have
said okay maybe we'll not put that much
pressure on you multilaterally we'll not
try to embarrass you but in exchange
maybe you can give our fishermen more
access
uh to resources in this car marshall
maybe you can stop uh harassing them so
there were many scenarios that we could
think about how to leverage this
award but none of that happened because
you have a president like duterte who
prioritized prioritizes
good relations with china perhaps above
you know the interests of the
philippines at times
now the u.s position on the south china
sea has also been seen as crucial to
this ongoing dispute and just over the
weekend
you had secretary of state anthony
blinken reiterate u.s support for the
philippines if it comes under attack
in the south china sea i'm wondering
based on what everything that you've
said
if that is a boost that the philippines
needed
to press on its legal advantage
right i mean this is the synchronicity
problem right uh when president aquino
was pushing ahead with this arbitration
award the philippines was not getting as
much support
up from then president barack obama was
very cautious was very reticent
uh to take it to to the chinese right
and in fact when the arbitration award
came out in 2016
five years ago president obama
immediately sent his top national
security advisor susan rice
to china in order to bring down tensions
that has not been the position
of his successors donald trump and biden
are taking very tough stance and sta
standing by the philippines the problem
is that they cannot be holier than the
pope
the philippines itself has to stand for
itself before his allies can stand for
it and this is the problem we're facing
today
richard hederian thank you so much for
joining us today